i'm here with john resig our our
resident javascript and all things
hardcore guru
i think so and also the architect behind
what we're looking at right now
what is this yeah this is this is really
exciting this is the new khan academy uh
computer science content uh we've been
working on this now for
for a little while and i'm i'm just
really excited to get this out now and
and so this is a page so we have i see a
bunch of links right here there's an
introductory video so what we're doing
right now is in the introductory video
it's the launch video yes there's
another introductory video that walks
through all of the stuff but let's let's
talk a little bit about what this
computer science is so fundamentally
you've created kind of a neat
environment uh so let's go so here's
some of the example programs that people
have done already on on this on this
platform really that you've you've made
so here are some of the getting started
ones let's let's play with so this is
the most basic one winston yeah yeah so
you got some ellipses and uh
lipstick and it's an environment where
you have right over here you have your
coding pane on the left and then you
have a canvas to draw so it's
immediately visual so this is something
that's pretty basic even for an early
programmer and and what i find very
exciting is some of this action that you
can change things in real time yeah so
and there's tutorials that go into more
depth i can make winston closer to my
complexion
there you go and we can we can change
things in real time so even for a
beginning programmer they can start to
to play around with things but obviously
this is actually what's been surprised a
fairly powerful
it's a fairly powerful environment yeah
being able to have that that
responsiveness i feel like it allows you
to just kind of better understand you
know how things you know interact with
each other
at a pretty fundamental level
yeah we have things like this which is a
little bit more involved and we can
change
we can change in real time some of the
the core variables right over here so
the
initial spiral configuration we'll see
what happens if we changed it a little
bit well you can see how it immediately
changes everything
maximum radius what is this i don't even
know what that does
but
it does something it seems to get larger
oh yeah
it's the radius of the circle number of
points in the spiral itself
we can register because you're getting
less and less skinny yeah we got thinner
thinner thicker
yeah so this is this is fascinating yeah
there's all of these let me leave this
page
and so there's a ton of examples of what
people have already done all the way to
this i guess this expert level you have
this is uh ben came as wrote this void
it's literally a bird flocking simulator
yeah but you can actually maybe this is
less realistic hit the birds with rock
yes
but this was all done i mean what's neat
is this was done all in this environment
it's all javascript right over here and
anyone can go and look at these and
change them yeah and then you can save
it as your you can save as and it'll
save it actually in your yeah in your
profile yeah the big thing we want to do
is we want we want everyone to be able
to see the code and the thing that's
running simultaneously and you should
always feel
willing and excited to change what's
there and make it your own uh uh so we
want to really heavily encourage
exploration and experimentation and i i
think this platform uh is is going to do
that
yeah this is this is neat and then you
can collect the stuff you so if you go
to a profile
it shows up there and you can share it
with other people
do so these are the things that i've
been working on i still have a little
work left to do but i had some simple i
want to do an ulaam spiral i can
actually show the current version of it
i've
made a little video on it too but yes
you just plot the prime numbers things
like that
and let's see how do we get here so
regardless so you go to
watch
computer science yep and then you click
there and it takes you to that main
computer science page and what if so we
just looked at a bunch of examples and
obviously people can look at the code
for those examples they can tweak it
they can save their own versions and and
maybe create derivative versions of them
what if someone's a complete beginner
what should they do
so i mean probably the the best way to
go about it is you know to
look at some things that you think are
kind of interesting you know like like
looking at some of the
introductory uh uh explorations you know
some of these programs here where you
know it's just you know just basic
drawing for example if you've never
programmed before this is a great way to
get started you know start to look at
what is being done there and see if you
can't you know kind of you know
see if you can kind of intuit like how
those you know you know function calls
work um and but but even so we have a
whole bunch of tutorials so like if you
go up to the
uh uh drawing tutorials there um like we
have a number of tutorials we have a few
tutorials on drawing along with you know
some of these programs that you you can
learn drawing from uh um and then if you
go up to um
you know if you want to learn some of
the uh basics of programming as well you
can you can view the programming basics
and we we go even into more depth about
like some of these topics that uh uh you
know you might want to understand better
and they also have like an audio
component yes our now soon to be famous
intern
jessica recorded many of these but if
you press play here you will actually
have her talking through what she's
doing here and she'll change the code in
the canvas yeah speaks and then you can
interact with that code yeah which is
pretty neat yeah most almost magical way
in my opinion and one thing that i found
really valuable even for myself is is to
it's sometimes fun to tweak other
people's code but once you feel
comfortable to actually just look at
what they did and try to build it
yourself from scratch because that's
really how you really learn to program
is get inspired see what's possible and
then try to build it yourself and if you
get really stuck then you see how other
people have have implemented things
and uh yeah so this is this is really
exciting do we miss anything no no i
mean yeah this is this is the big thing
i think the big thing we want to
encourage here is you know
we want you to
make your own things you know you know
not only building off of what we have
but create something original uh um you
know you can you know take components
from what we've written and or just
write stuff that's completely new
um a mercury subspace there is a pretty
awesome one that one i think people will
get a big kick out of that one and so
this whole game was written right here
yeah yep and that was done by
david one of our interns oh yeah this is
a real game yeah
this is uh yeah david david kind of
overdusting sometimes that's pretty good
this is oh oh yeah yeah and this was all
written there and someone can can change
how do i pause it uh i'll just just
click over outside of it oh okay so like
for example there you got your max
health so why don't you try changing max
health and look at the hearts in the
display up there so if i change my max
health to 10 then all of a sudden we
have more hearts here
so this is fun you can i mean even a
very beginner could start changing a
fairly sophisticated
program you could change the images and
things like that oh yeah absolutely so
yeah yeah let me go down scroll down a
little bit so you got your guy there in
a little he's in a little beetle there
yeah oh there you go so there there's
one that's uh the second one down beetle
ship
so uh um
and why don't you click and scroll down
there a little bit
and um say spunky sam yeah go ahead uh
so why don't you click that and so uh uh
you can see there look at it oh so now
now now the ship is funky yeah now
you're shooting very cool
very cool so i mean i think this is sort
of you know one of the things we really
wanted to do is we really wanted to make
it powerful
you know
it's simple enough that anyone can
really get in and start to you know play
around um so
i think one of the you know the big
things here is that we want you to make
your own things and then down below you
you see that there is this you know
discussion area where you can ask
questions and and comment on things and
you know this is a big thing like i i i
think you're this you're going to find
this to be a really valuable way to get
feedback
and to
uh be able to talk with other people and
get a better understanding about how
things work and actually become a better
i mean one thing i found is just writing
a couple of these tutorials getting
feedback from you and other people has i
think made me better because there's
little silly things that i kept doing
and now all of a sudden other people can
look at it find other interesting ways
of doing it or even asking or you know
and you could ask the author questions
about how they have done something so
yeah it's a community of uh of learners
here yeah no absolutely this is exciting
yeah i already have two or three
projects that i'm i'm not getting much
other other things done right now
great yeah i love it too i've been
having a blast playing around with it